Okay, everyone. We'll start in
30 seconds, when it turns 12:30.
Well, you could just sit here. Yeah, I'll call you.
Okay, it's 12:30, so I want us to start on time and be on time.
So welcome, everyone, and
I'm Anirban Maitra. I'm the cancer center director at Perlmutter Cancer Center
at New York University, and it's great to have you
all. It's been quite a month for this disease.
I had this title, I have to say this title, a long
time before all of the news of the past week came out, but it really feels
like a very opportune title, "Turning the Tide in the Fight Against
Pancreas Cancer."
So just for the record, as a pathologist, I have to show this slide.
This is what ductal adenocarcinoma looks like.
These are some of the diagnostic sine qua nons that we look
at under the microscope or now increasingly on the computer
screen. Desmoplasia, this intense stromal reaction,
lymphatic invasion, vascular invasion, and perineural invasion
that you see in the bottom.
These are the grim statistics. It is the third most common cause of
cancer-related deaths in the US,
and its incidence is rising. This is from the Pancreas Cancer
Statistics 2026 paper that the ACS puts out in the middle of
January each year and is the highest-cited paper for the year.
This is the stage distribution for pancreas cancer.
More than half of the patients present with distant metastatic disease, about a
third with regional disease, and only about 15%,
sometimes 20%, depending on the numbers, are patients who are localized
and are able to undergo surgical resection.
And this is really the subset where we have seen true long-term
survival. Only very rarely do we have patients with
stage four metastatic disease who have survived long-term.
One of them is in the audience. Steve, thank you.
But really that is more of an outlier than the
norm. And part of the reason is the remarkable molecular
heterogeneity of advanced pancreatic cancer.
This is from a study we published last year showing just how
distinct, molecularly even, two concurrent
liver metastases are in the same patient from this rapid autopsy series.
And this is a wonderful review. And again, many of you in this audience are
pancreas cancer aficionados, so this is not for you.
But if you are new, if you're a trainee, this is a wonderful review written by Dave
Tuveson and Paige Ferguson
called "The Roadmap to Conquering Pancreas Cancer." And in that, they have
this seven deadly hallmarks of pancreas cancer figure.
I like it because it really nicely captures the challenges that
we all face in terms of making an advance against this disease.
So it's been gloom and doom for a very long time, but is there
finally cause for optimism? We've had some really
very uplifting news in the last,
even last week, 10 days. You can see a very nerdy-looking Vinod
on CNN right there talking about the vaccine study that he presented
yesterday. We have multiple RAS talks today.
I will clarify, we are not going to discuss about the phase
three RESOLUTE-302 data here, in case anyone--
You have the opportunity to walk out still if you want to.
That data is going to be presented at ASCO by Brian Volpin.
That news just came out. It's going to be an ASCO plenary.
But anyway, we have
some cause for optimism finally.
And so my goal and the goal of the
very distinguished speaker panel we have today is to bust a few
pancreatic cancer myths, and four of them in particular.
Number one, KRAS is an undruggable target.
I mean, we all wrote this in our reviews and papers and grants
even just a few years ago.
Pancreatic cancers have few expressed neoantigens.
This gets mentioned quite a bit.
CA19-9 is a biomarker. This is what you're always taught in medical school, but
has no role in disease biology. And
pancreatic cancer cannot be stopped in its tracks.
And this myth has not been busted, but we made, I think,
a significant dent in this. So our myth busters are
Shubham Pant, who will start us off.
Wilfried Pastor who's also one of the ACR NextGen
awardees. Very proud to have him here in our speaker list.
Danny Engel from the Salk Institute, and then yours
truly will bring it home. So without further ado, Dr.
Pant is going to talk about recent advances in treatment of pancreas cancer.
Thank you.
Thank you, Anirban. Good afternoon, everyone, to beautiful San
Diego. And a lot has happened in the last
week, and I have 15 minutes, but I'm going to take the five minutes from the
question time and speak for 20 minutes because I have 50 slides.
So get ready for the ride.
How do I advance this, Anirban?
Yes. You can just click the down button if you want.
Oh, you have to click on your talk. Click on your talk.
Oh, hold on.
Click on your talk, it'll open up.
There we go.
Start,
and let's go. So this is MD Anderson.
This used to be here, Anirban's office. Anirban, it's nice.
It's in 70s in Houston right now, so
congratulations on your move to New York.
Anyways, these are my disclosures.
What is the challenge in pancreatic cancer?
And Anirban has told you this already.
Majority of the patients present with late-stage disease, and the
five-year prognosis for metastatic disease is still under
5%.
So what is the current treatment for metastatic PDAC?
This was my slide two weeks ago.And this is how to change it, right?
So chemotherapy, I think, was the mainstay of
treatment for PDAC patients in the second-line setting.
And after ASCO, we'll look at the ASCO data that Brian will
present to change the treatment paradigm.
But if you're uninitiated into the world of pancreatic cancer, the way
we treat patients with stage four disease when they present, we either give them
FOLFIRINOX, NALIRIFOX or Gemabraxane.
And then for second-line, if they got a 5-FU frontline, we give them a gem-based
second line. And if they got a gem-based first line, we give them a 5-FU second
line. But importantly, less than 50% of
patients get second-line therapy.
We really don't have any third-line treatment options for our patients with
pancreatic cancer.
So if Anirban had called me to give this talk in 2022,
I would have finished in two minutes, right? That would be my talk.
So I said, "I'm done with-- this is the treatment for pancreatic cancer.
Thank you so much." However, we have moved from famine to definitely a
feast in this disease.
And this is why. So these are potential molecular
targets in PDAC, and I'm presenting this slide because
a number of these now have targeted therapies for
them. So finding the target. So
what's the target first? So let me start first on KRAS wild-type
pancreatic cancer. That is 10% of the patient population has
KRAS wild type. And interestingly, if you're younger than 50
years of age-- So pancreatic cancer is a disease of aging mostly.
We see mostly patients in their 70s and 80s.
But if you're under 50, about 20% can
have KRAS wild-type disease. And this is important because
40% of KRAS wild type can have some targetable alteration, a
fusion or a mutation. And the way we try to find
therapies for patients who are needles,
who are really a small number, less than 1%, is with basket
trials. So if you look at NTRK fusion, RET fusion, ALK fusion,
FGFR2 fusion, we've run basket trials of
agents like larotrectinib and entrectinib in NTRK fusion.
But I'll tell you,
treating probably hundreds if not thousands of patients with pancreatic cancer, I
probably have two or three patients with NTRK fusions.
So it's rare, but when you find it, it's clinically very
relevant for the patient because we can see response rates of 30 or 40% with these
agents.
But what about the haystack? And the haystack is obviously KRAS.
Why is it undruggable? I agree with Anirban we should retire the word soon,
but essentially, there's a high affinity of KRAS for
GTP. It's tightly bound, and the KRAS proteins
have a smooth surface and an absence of a binding pocket, and that's why it's been
so hard to drug this target.
But how do we go about cracking KRAS?
So the way I see it, it's a dam, and we are blowing up the dam in different places.
And we are truly cracking KRAS now.
And this is a chart of KRAS drug discovery
identified in the 1960s and '70s. 2013, I'm
going to talk about some breakthroughs, and now we are at 2025,
2026, really leading the charge to changing the
treatment outcomes for our patients with this disease.
So first of all, in 2013,
it changed from undruggable to druggable.
Kevin Shawcat's group found this binding pocket in the switch II region
of G12C. We had G12C
inhibitors, which bound to KRAS off and led
to blockade of downstream signaling. And we did a trial.
Again, we did this basket trial called CRYSTAL-1,
and this was with a drug called adagrasib.
Again, it was a basket trial. Twenty-one patients in our
trial had metastatic pancreatic cancer.
And if you look at the response rate, it was about 33%.
Now, this was very significant to us because when you look at
chemotherapy in the second-line setting, the response rate is 10 to
15%. That's what we see. But we almost doubled the response rate
with adagrasib.
So adagrasib and its kind of another drug, sotorasib, is part of
the NCCN guidelines for our patients with KRAS
G12C pancreatic cancer.
But what's the challenge? It's about 1.5% of our patients, right?
Hence, we did the basket trial. It's not like colorectal or lung.
So what is it truly which we need to do in pancreatic cancer is
these mutations. So you have KRAS G12D,
as in delta, 40%, V as in Victor,
30%, R as in Romeo, 15%. Those are the three most
common mutant alleles in pancreatic cancer.
And why these are different, we looked at retrospectively at our
Anderson
patients who had NGS, and what we find is the mutant alleles do
differently. So if you're KRAS wild type, and if you're
KRAS G12R, you tend to do the best. So your median survival is pushing two
years. D and V is somewhere in the middle, that 12-month survival,
and Q61s tend to do the worst. So there is a prognostic
difference in the way you look at the mutant alleles.
So truly, so that was cracking KRAS, but we are
truly starting the RAS revolution, and we are starting
with this drug called deraxone rasip. So on rasip, right?
Ras on, I-B, on rasip. So deraxone rasip, think
about it like a molecular glue binds to cyclophilin A,
and this binds to RAS on. Remember adagrasib bound
to RAS off. This binds to RAS on and causes steric
occlusion.
And this was our phase one deraxone rasip trial.
In the early phases, this was run by Clay Gustafson
from Revolution Medicine. And at that time-When
this graph, this waterfall plot came out.
So the waterfall plots for the trainees in here, anything going above that
line, it shows you that the disease, the target lesions, are growing.
Anything going below that line means that target lesions are shrinking.
And honestly, in pancreatic cancer, we had never seen these graphs before.
Small number of patients, overall response rate was
36%. Progression-free survival was 8.8 months.
And honestly, I still remember having, gosh taken care of
or looked at patients maybe 2022 on this trial.
I still remember the first time I saw a patient.
It was a patient with pancreatic cancer with lung mets, and I could see
when I saw the scans, they were shrinking.
And I was like, "This is a real drug." I mean, it's causing these reductions
in patients' tumor sizes.
There are side effects associated with the drug.
About 90% of patients get a rash. You can also see diarrhea,
nausea and vomiting, and stomatitis in the patients.
About 10% can get a grade three rash.
The way we mitigate is we give antibiotics, we give skin creams.
We have to hold the drug for some patients and dose adjust, and then the
patients can normally stay on the therapy.
Based on this phase one data, we launched the Resolute 302 trial.
I think it was just like a year, year and a half back.
I think it's been like a decade ago.
It enrolled really rapidly and
being a pancreatic cancer doctor, having done a lot of pancreatic cancer,
you're always cautiously optimistic, right?
And I'm normally a zen person, but I was
honestly a little bit
tense over the last year, and this is why.
Because I participated in the Napoli 1
trial, which led to the approval of 5-FU liposome, Irinotecan, and just
negative trial after negative trial after that.
So while I was enthusiastic about the data, I was
still cautiously optimistic. Turns out last Monday,
when I was just about to start clinic of, I would say, our 26,
27 patients, 70% were pancreatic, 30% biliary, where
RAS is also an important target
this came out. And my phone just started going crazy.
People are texting me from all over.
I actually saw a patient on this trial right after this news came out,
and I'm talking to this patient about it, and it was a really great moment.
But a hazard ratio of 0.4, we have not
seen these numbers in pancreatic cancer before.
Even in GI cancer, we see them in, let's say, MSI high GI cancers,
BRAF, but those are 5% of cancers. This is
applicable to a majority, if not all the patients with
pancreatic cancer. And as Anirban said, this will be presented
by Brian in
ASCO's Plenary Session. So really excited to look at
the data in detail. But this was very impactful for our patients.
One of the drugs, if you are old enough to remember,
Erlotinib was approved for pancreatic cancer for a survival benefit of two weeks.
So this is truly, I think, transformational for our patients.
Excited to see the data.
Based on some data, which is going to be presented after my talk from
Brian Wolpin and Eileen O'Reilly.
In the frontline we did combinations of gem/nab
paclitaxel with duraxon rasib and duraxon rasib single agent.
And based on the data, we launched this global phase III trial called
Resolute 303. Because remember, only 50% of pancreatic
cancer patients get a second line, right?
So we want to get this benefit to the majority of our patients who are showing up
to our clinic. So patients will be randomized to duraxon rasib
in combination with gem/nab paclitaxel or gem/nab
paclitaxel. And if somebody had told me three years ago that we would be giving a
pill to treat pancreatic cancer in the frontline setting, I would not have believed
them. But this is the data. Again, I thank you, Anirban, for tweeting this out.
So I took this from Anirban's tweet.
This is about 50% response rate
frontline single agent and a 60% response rate
frontline in combination with gem/nab paclitaxel.
If you're around this afternoon, please do attend these sessions to get more
granular view of this data.
All right. So we've just gotten started. This is PANRAS.
Now we go on to the RAS G12D agents, which we
also have clinical data on.
So this is, you can think about it like a sister drug to duraxon rasib.
It's zoldonrasib, and this is the KRASG12D
inhibitor. It's a RAS on agent.
Response rates with this agent is about
30%. But the interesting thing about this compound is it's a
very clean compound. That means you don't get a lot of side
effects with single agent zoldonrasib.
And that's important because you can combine it with chemotherapy and
that's why it's important to mention that.
I sometimes think about duraxon rasib and zoldonrasib like "Game of Thrones"
dragons, like breathing fire down on RAS. I'm sorry. I'm just seeing it right now.
This is the second drug, is setigrasib.
It's a KRASG12D protein degrader.
You have single-agent
efficacy, and then in combination, small numbers with
fulvestrant. And
then you have INCB734. Again, this was presented at
ASCO GI this year. Response rate, single agent, about
37%. Again, just like the
other D inhibitor, majority of the toxicities are
grade one and grade two.
So based on this, and it's a really exciting time to be a pancreatic
cancer physician. So I encourage young trainees to think about this as a career
choice because things are changing.
There are four phase III trials being launched in the frontline.
Resolute 305, which is zoldon plus fulvestrant or
gem/nab paclitaxel. Dawn 303, which is 734
which is fairly a similar trial. Resolute 309,
which is zoldonrasib with duraxonrasib, novel-novel.
PANRAS plus D versus gem/nab paclitaxel.
And the setigrasib trial,
I guess they didn't have a clever name for it, but hopefully they'll come up with
one. But it's essentially the drug, the
degrader with nalidifox or
fulvestrant.Coming to where we go next.
So this was the secondary alteration.
So when you give duraxon rasib, one is the response rate, and we do
see durability of response, but we want to make this durability of
response better for our patients.
So when you look at mechanisms of resistance, about a
majority of patients do have some mechanism of resistance, KRS amplification being
the most common.
So how do we tackle this? And we tackle this with what Jesse
Boehm of Breakthrough Cancer says, radical collaboration.
So this was a truly collaborative effort between Dana-Farber,
Hopkins, Memorial Sloan Kettering, MD Anderson,
Mallika Singh leading the charge from Revolution Medicine as an industry
partner. And what we said was, we want to know what this
drug does in the patient and what are the
mechanisms of resistance. So we,
in the clinical sites did about-- and NYU is joining this also, and
there's so many people, I can't name all of them, but everybody's
played a great role in this. So we said, okay, we'll get the tumor biopsy at
baseline, tumor biopsy in two weeks, and at progression.
And in pancreatic cancer, when you try to do paired tumor biopsies,
historically in clinical trials, we're able to get 5% to 10% of tumor
biopsies.
We did 50 tumor boards, and some of them were at
6:00 in the morning in Texas, so thank you to my East Coast colleagues.
And with 50 tumor boards, 66 patients, and we got paired tumor
biopsies on 85% of patients. And there'll be a lot of data
coming out. We had our KRS team lab, which is led by our
fearless leader, Andy Guerry.
A lot of data will be coming out. I'll show you one slide, but there are 100 plus
slides of data, so just watch this space over the next year.
So this was presented in ASCO RAS by Mallika,
and I did this for Anirban because I know you love these slides, Anirban.
But essentially, the important thing in this is when you give
duraxon rasib, in two weeks, when you re-biopsy, and these
were liver lesions, in two weeks when you biopsy, and we try to biopsy the same
liver lesion. So in two weeks, when you biopsy the liver lesion, you can see a
reduction in tumor cell density, and you can see that in these 12
patients what that reduction in tumor cell density was.
So a lot of
data is going to come out on the microenvironment, mechanism of resistance.
Really excited about this space in the future.
I'm going to just go from RAS to the other target that I think is
very relevant in pancreatic cancer, MTAP.
MTAP and CDK2 and twoA are co-deleted normally.
They're on chromosome 9.
So if you have loss of MTAP, you accumulate MTA.
It binds to an enzyme called PRMT5, and PRMT5 inhibitors in the
tumor cell result in insult on injury,
basically, injury on insult, essentially.
And this is one of their number of drugs out there.
This is one of the drugs which is called Navly
metastat. It's a PRMT5
inhibitor. And interestingly, the response rate is about 25%
in the second-line setting. But the time to response, and I want you to focus,
sorry, on this, it's about five months.
However, this is called a spider plot.
That means instead of that waterfall plot, this looks at each patient and looks
at the journey of each patient. So that's a very important thing.
So this drug is different because the first scan you do can lead to a
reduction of 10%. Thirty percent is when we say research response.
Then it goes to 20%. But when you get that 20,
30%, this is a durable response. So that's important
because getting a response is important, but the durability of response
is what we really look for as clinical benefit to our patient.
So interesting drug, and it's
not a lot of grade three-- mostly grade one and two side effects.
Based on this, we launched this trial, MOUNTAIN-AP30, which is a two phase II/III
trial in combination with Gem/Nab-Paclitaxel.
And more excitingly, can you go to the next step?
Inhibit PRMT5 and RAS and those trials have already
started.
Quickly, just finishing up with
lymph node with this vaccine that we did a study
on, reported it a couple of years ago.
Again, there's an albumin binding lipid, PEG linker, and a
peptide. The peptide was KRS G12D and R.
And essentially, this was a trial.
This was in resected pancreatic cancer patients, 20 pancreatic,
five colorectal, high risk of recurrence, MRD positive, or CA19-9
was going up. We did this phase I trial, and what we saw
was that if you have a response above this
median threshold of T cell, then those patients tend to have a better
recurrence-free survival and a better overall survival.
And based on that, we did this phase II trial.
It was randomized, two is to one, seven-peptide vaccine
versus
follow-up in patients who are resected pancreatic cancer.
So NED, but trying to decrease the chance of recurrence.
And this is an early look at the translational data.
We are awaiting the results, formal results, sometime soon this year.
But if you look at the translational data, about 80% of the patients
did have above the threshold of a T cell response.
But the clinical data is awaited, which should be available soon.
So I think to finish, hopefully near on time, the future
is bright.
This came out in 2022
in "The New York Times," but now look at all the other AI
engines. And this is how I look at it.
So as a drug developer in pancreatic cancer, when I used to go
to companies or to patients, we used to get a saltine c*****r for
appetizer, glass of water for
the main course, and no dessert, right?
But now we have a buffet for our patients, which is amazing.
We can show them these trials. We just need more slots on them, but it's
just an exciting time to be in this space.
And what does the future look like?
In my clinic, maybe in three months from now in clinical trials, and hopefully in
the future, if a patient comes to me with metastatic cancer, we'll do the
tumor NGS. That's important in pancreatic cancer patients.If
KRAS, you can get a pan-KRAS or a pan-KRAS with chemo.
You have a D, you can get a pan-KRAS chemo combo or with
pan-KRAS. If you have an MTAP loss, maybe MTAP and pan-KRAS or a
PRMT5 plus chemo. I haven't touched on claudin because I don't have time, but
that's also up and coming. So lots of excitement in this space.
So how do I see KRAS drug discovery?
Living in Houston, 1969, land on the moon, and then we got to see these
beautiful images from Artemis, which they call it the far side of the moon.
I like to call the dark side of the moon.
But finishing up, I think majority of folks in this
room, I'm sure, are interested in pancreatic cancer research.
And I think for one of the first times, we have this amazing
foundation to build on for our patients to really improve
the survival in this disease. So I'm going to end with a poem from my
childhood which says, and I think this is relevant to a lot of us in this room,
"The woods are lovely, dark and deep, but I have promises to keep, and miles to go
before I sleep, and miles to go before I sleep." Thank you so much.
Let's get to work. Thank you, Niranjan, for the thought.
Thank you.
Thank you. On time.
Thank you. In the interest of time, we'll
move on. As you probably guessed, Shubham does not sleep, so
our next speaker is Wilfried Pastor from Dana-Farber, and he's going to
talk about cryptic antigens in pancreas cancer.
All right. Thanks.
Awesome.
So while it's loading up, just a huge thank you to the organizers and to
Anirban for the invitation to speak today.
So Wilfried Pastor, physician scientist at Dana-Farber.
Really excited to talk not about KRAS, actually.
Well, it'll make it into a slide or two, but actually on our work
on antigen discovery in pancreatic
cancer, work that has really centered in
on the role for non-canonical or cryptic antigens
in this disease.
These are my disclosures.
Now, Shubham already introduced pancreatic cancer more broadly.
Let me focus in because my lab thinks about this disease with a
specific lens of how to harness the
anti-tumor immune response in this disease.
And I will say that for a long time, this was thought of really
as a bit of a fool's errand, right? We know that pancreatic
cancer is almost completely refractory, at
least to traditional immune checkpoint blockade.
This has been chalked up to a number of different phenomena, but most
prominently, the profoundly immune-suppressive
tumor microenvironment that really typifies this disease, as
well as the low to intermediate mutational burden that is common in
pancreatic cancer, really, and then postulated that perhaps there
were just no neoantigens to actually see.
As we've already heard, that myth is starting to get busted.
Work from my own group, Vinod Balachandran, Steve Rosenberg, and many
others, have really demonstrated that a subset of
pancreatic cancer patients do in fact harbor at least
predicted high-quality neoantigens.
We've seen tremendously exciting efforts, early-stage
clinical efforts, but demonstrating that it is possible to
elicit robust tumor-specific T cell
responses in this disease. And while small number
of patients, I think very, very compelling data coming out
demonstrating that cellular therapies can actually function
in pancreatic cancer using neoantigen-directed
TCR-engineered T cells or TCR T cells.
So with this in mind, we said, well, if we're going to
really develop effective antigen-directed therapies,
we actually need to understand what this peptide HLA
complex actually looks like and describe the antigen
landscape in pancreatic cancer.
So if we think about the tumor antigen landscape more broadly
across cancer, we've focused over the past many years on
cancer-associated viruses, obviously don't really play a role here for pancreas
cancer, but on tumor-associated antigens and somatic
mutations, and seen tremendous excitement in those.
But what I'd like to introduce at the beginning here is that we're really just
scratching the surface of the targetable tumor antigen
landscape. The past couple years from many
groups have shown actually that cancer cells more broadly,
including now pancreatic cancer, that they go haywire, not just
transcriptionally, but also translationally, that you start
translating areas of the putatively
non-protein coding genome.
This can include these novel unannotated open reading frames,
as well as endogenous retroviruses, other transposable
elements that can both be transcriptionally misregulated, but
also be translated, giving rise to HLA-1 bound
peptides in cancer. And really elegant work from Reuven
Agami's group has actually demonstrated that under certain stress
conditions, cancer cells actually recurrently
misincorporate the wrong amino acid, leading to
non-genetically templated missense mutations that
actually can be recognized by T cells.
Let me spend the next few minutes talking about our work
actually on these novel unannotated open reading
frames in pancreatic cancer.
So how do we get there? Again, we want to actually ask,
instead of just computational predictions, what if we
use newer technologies, including mass spec technologies, to
directly survey the antigen landscape in this disease?
So we took a number of patient biospecimens, either direct from patients or
patient-derived organoids,
did extensive genomic and transcriptomic profiling on these,
ultimately followed by immunoprecipitation of
HLA class II complexes, elution of peptides, followed
by mass spec, a process termed immunopeptidomics.
And this is just to highlight that this is a large collaborative effort among many
groups at the Hale Family Center for Pancreatic Cancer Research,
as well as close colleagues at MIT.The
immunopeptidomics, the mass spec part of it, was all done at the
Broad Institute through the proteomics platform there, and really
spearheaded by Steve Carr and Jen Abelin.
And we were excited to see that we were able to get tremendous
depth of profiling, now directly detecting anywhere
between 8,000 to over 18,000
unique class I associated peptides per patient
sample.
But beyond just the depth. Because we had whole genome
sequencing, we were able to do mutation calls, HLA typing, and
create a personalized proteogenomic search space on
each and every patient, and now actually, very rewardingly,
directly detect mutation-encoded
neoepitopes on this disease, really fitting with many of
ours and others' computational predictions, which was very
exciting.
On the other hand, it was also very humbling.
If we look at the number of exonic mutations that we're
able to detect by whole genome sequencing, here on the left, compared to
the number of mutation-encoded neoepitopes detectable by mass spec on
the right, they're few and far between, despite the profound depth that we're
getting. And so we started asking ourselves, well, clearly mutations
are targets for the subset of patients that have them, but what about the
patients where we can't actually empirically detect
mutation-encoded neoepitopes? The time was right that
Cathy Wu, Aviv Regev, Claude Perrault, and others had begun
describing in other tumor types this concept of novel,
unannotated open reading frames in cancer, these so-called new
ORFs. Just briefly, I've introduced the overall dark proteome, but these
are thought to arise from aberrant translation
outside of annotated protein coding genomes.
So we can think about translation of the five-prime or three-prime
UTR, translation in the wrong reading frame, these so-called
intORFs, and importantly, this is not due to a frame-shifting mutation,
but actually ribosomal promiscuity, so translation in the plus
one or plus two reading frame, translation of link RNAs,
and many others. So with this in mind, we augmented our
proteomic search space to see whether this was actually true in pancreatic cancer.
Lo and behold, it was, of course.
Instead of one or two peptides per patient sample, now we're
detecting tens to hundreds, and actually in every patient sample that we
look at, making up anywhere between about 2% to over
8% of the overall immunopeptidome.
Now, these fell into a number of different defined categories or biotypes, and we
saw a clear predilection in pancreatic cancer for
translation of five-prime UTRs, and then these
intORFs, so translation in alternative reading frames, but
clear evidence for a number of these different new ORF
biotypes in patient-derived organoids.
Now, to make sure, though, that this was not some artifact of
organotypic culture, we went back to bulk
tumors directly out of the patient right after Whipple resection and put these
through the identical immunopeptidomic workflow, and we're
really pleased to see that, in fact, we could see the same
non-canonical open reading frame translation was
preserved in the primary tumors, and many of the peptides are
actually shared between bulk tumors and organoids, even despite
the fact that these are from different patients.
So this was all exciting, and we said, "Well, great.
We've detected these cryptic peptides or these non-canonical peptides in
pancreatic cancer." But honestly, these had been well worked out in other
tumor types before this. So we took a bit of a step back and said, "Well, what is
not known about this field of the dark
proteome more broadly?" And a number of questions were unanswered
at that time, and we'll go through them, that we've tried to answer
each one in line. The first being,
what is the real evidence that these non-canonical or
cryptic peptides are truly tumor specific?
They're outside of annotated protein coding genes, but it's people like
us that do these annotations, and so did we just get the annotations wrong?
The other is, what is the mechanism of non-canonical ORF
translation in cancer more broadly?
And then can these actually, we know they're presented on HLA class 1, but can
they be recognized by CD8 T cells? Are these really immunogenic?
And if so, what's the real therapeutic potential for
targeting these?
So first, to assess tumor specificity.
Because these are thought to arise from aberrant
translation in cancer, we wanted to create a
translation-centric view of healthy tissues, and
here, using a few hundred healthy tissues profiled
by HLA class 1 immunopeptidomics, as well as
ribosome sequencing, spanning 28 different organ
systems, including healthy thymus.
We asked the question, can we detect any evidence of these
non-canonical open reading frames in healthy tissues?
And the first takeaway was that some we can.
So meaning many of these are actually likely
misannotations and do occur in healthy tissues.
However, for about 500, a little over a third of these, we could find
zero evidence of translation in any healthy tissue that we
profiled, and now we've profiled many more since then.
And so we termed these cancer-restricted cryptic
peptides or cancer-restricted cryptic antigens.
What got us excited about this is not just that they are specific to cancer,
but that they're often shared across patients, unlike many
mutation-encoded neoepitopes.These are shared, of course, by
patients with the correct HLA restriction element.
But in HLA-A*02:01, we found about half of our
cancer-restricted cryptic antigens were shared by two or more patients,
with a subset actually shared in over 70% of
A*02:01 positive patients. This
opens up the potential for off-the-shelf therapies if we can
actually provoke a CD8 T cell response against them.
And so again, to directly ask the question, can these be immunogenic,
we first adopted and then adapted an approach to do ex
vivo T cell priming and expansion, where we use
HLA-matched healthy donor peripheral blood mononuclear cells,
differentiate our own dendritic cells, use these to prime and
expand autologous CD8 T cells, and read out
immunogenicity using both HLA class I tetramers and effector
cytokine secretion. We're really pleased to see that
actually a subset of these non-canonical peptides did show
immunogenic potential. About a quarter of them were positive in
these assays, but actually much more excited when we broke these
up into which were predicted to be cancer restricted
versus non-cancer restricted based on our platform.
As one would hope, the cancer restricted fraction was highly enriched
in immunogenic peptides, although I highlight that we were theoretically able
to break tolerance to a small set of non-cancer restricted
cryptic peptides.
We really wanted to benchmark this against more classic
neoantigens, and so empirically tested all of
the directly identified mutation-encoded neoepitopes, as
well as a set of computationally predicted
neoantigens. Clearly, mutations can be immunogenic.
We have seen that in humans as well already in patients,
and firm believer still in mutations.
But our takeaway from this data was actually that cancer-restricted cryptic
antigens are about on par with these
more traditional classes of neoantigens.
So we want to go a bit further into this and actually discover T cell
receptors specific to these neoantigens, both the mutations and the
cancer-restricted cryptic antigens.
To do this, we had to develop pipelines, and so using DNA
barcoded HLA class I tetramers paired with the 10x genomics
pipeline, we can now at scale isolate full-length
TCR alpha beta with paired antigen specificity.
We've done this to identify a suite of cryptic
antigen-specific TCRs across a range of
different biotypes, take these, and we can molecularly
reconstruct these, and then perform CRISPR-based
TCR redirection to create TCR T cells.
These TCR T cells can then be put back into co-culture with the
tumor cells from which we did the immunopeptidomics, right?
So testing against the patient-derived organoids, can these
actually recognize and kill tumor cells expressing
endogenous levels of their cognate antigen?
And that's exactly what we saw across multiple different cryptic
antigen-specific TCRs, even targeting different biotypes.
We saw quite exquisite cytotoxicity, even at low
effector-to-target ratios. We've now done this in vitro as
cell lines, ex vivo as patient-derived organoids, but also
in vivo using randomized and blinded preclinical studies to
test adoptive cell therapy using TCRT in these models,
demonstrating, again, for the first time that cryptic antigen-specific
TCRs can exert tumorocidal activity in any
cancer type, in fact. But this, I will say, is proof of concept.
This was truly TCR001, the first one we ever
identified, and we were able to profoundly delay tumor progression,
but not completely eradicate these tumors, and I think that's important to
highlight. So now in unpublished work, we've tried to expand this and ask the
question, well, why couldn't we eradicate these tumors?
And so one question is, is the actual antigen
heterogeneity. So we've now been testing
combinations of targeting multiple
distinct cancer-restricted cryptic antigens, showing that these can actually
augment cytotoxicity against patient-derived
PDOC organoids. Here, even in long-term IncuCyte
assays, just targeting just two can nearly eradicate
these patient-derived organoids.
So we think that this is a very exciting time and really poised for
clinical translation.
So let me just summarize, hopefully convince you all that this
newer class of non-canonical HLA-1 bound
peptides are abundant in the pancreatic cancer
immunopeptidome. A subset of these are cancer
restricted, shared across patients, and harbor
robust immunogenic potential. A subset of these, we
can find cryptic antigen-specific TCRs that are
actually able to recognize and kill tumor cells, importantly
expressing endogenous levels of their peptide.
So quickly, just to thank the people who actually did the work.
I tried to acknowledge people throughout, but this work was really spearheaded by
two individuals, Zach Ely and Zach Halstead, who started with me in Tyler
Jacks's lab, moved over with me to Dana-Farber when I started my lab about four
years ago, and then really carried forward by Gerjon Gunadin
and Sudarsana Adipali in my group.
But close collaboration with Tyler Jacks at MIT, Steve
Carr and Jen Abelin at the Broad Institute, Phil Greenberg at Fred
Hutch, and many investigators at Dana-Farber.
And so just a huge thank you to all of our funding sources that made this possible,
the patients who contributed their tissues, and thank you to you guys for
listening.
Yeah.
We have a little bit of buffer in the end for questions.
I'm going to ask all the speakers to stay. Hold on to your questions.
So our next speaker is Dani Engel from the Salk Institute, and she's going to talk
about all the mysteries of CA19-9 and some model work she's
been doing.
Great. Thank you. Let me...
All right. Hello everybody, and thank you so much for the invitation to speak
today. It is really an inspiring time to be part of the pancreas cancer
community, and this meeting is really special because it bridges
both the discoveries that are immediately clinically translatable, but also the
fundamental science that's really behind a lot of those discoveries.
And so today, I'm going to take a step back and continue to build on work that I
started as a postdoctoral fellow at Cold Spring Harbor with David
Tuveson, understanding how the glycan CA19-9 contributes to
pancreatic tumor genesis. And this has really been a
project led by two PhD students in my lab, Heman
and Jasper, both of whom are finishing up in the next few months.
So I don't receive any money from companies, unfortunately, but I
do have grants.
All right. So we talk about CA19-9 a lot in terms of using it to
follow treatment response in patients with pancreas cancer.
If your tumors are growing, your CA19-9 levels in your
blood go up, and if your tumors are regressing, your CA19-9
levels will go down. So CA19-9 itself is actually a blood
group antigen called Sialyl Lewis a, and it's a type of glycan
modification added to hundreds of different proteins,
especially in pancreatic cancer cells.
And so, as I mentioned, it's this Sialyl Lewis a blood group antigen, which is
really what we would call a truncated glycan that leads to a
complete change in its ability to functionally interact with other
proteins.
And so when I was a
postdoctoral fellow, I wanted to study this molecule, one, because I was interested
in early detection, and this has really been one of the field standards for
decades, but two, because there were hints in the literature that it might actually
play a functional role in cell signaling.
And so a lot of the data is very difficult to mine in terms of having
CA19-9 levels and prognoses, but in this recent study,
a couple of years ago, they had really good metadata.
And what I was able to do is actually take a look at very small tumors, so
stage one, node-negative resections, and show that
even in this context, with the exact same tumor sizes, all
resectable, you can see that the patients with high CA19-9 levels have a
substantially reduced overall disease-free survival.
And so to investigate this question many years ago in Dave's lab, I wanted to
study it in our mouse models. It's very complicated in terms of
studying a lot of this biology in people.
And we have these amazing mouse models that Dave helped develop in Tyler Jack's
lab, where we can induce exactly the same KRAS mutation that's most commonly
observed in patients in the pancreas of mice.
But I ran into a small hiccup in that mice, turn out, are
very different from people in that they don't make CA19-9.
The enzyme responsible for the final sialylation step,
fucosyltransferase 3, is a pseudogene in all rodents.
And so right away, that tells you that CA19-9 is not necessary for pancreatic tumor
genesis. But I wanted to see if it played any sort of role in
accelerating it. And so I figured out how to make CA19-9 in mice, and I
created a series of mouse models that enabled me to induce CA19-9
elevation, either just in the mouse pancreas, bile duct, and duodenum, or in the
whole body of a mouse. And right away, you might wonder, does that cause just a
massive autoimmune reaction? And the quick answer is no.
We've studied this a lot because, in the beginning, we thought this could be an
artifact instead of cool biology.
And so I'm happy to take you through all that data offline.
But most importantly is that when we turn it on in the entire body of the mouse,
we only see signs of inflammation in the pancreas.
And so that, to us, tells us there's something very specific about the importance
of CA19-9 to pancreatic biology.
And when we turn on CA19-9, the mice rapidly develop pancreatitis, and if
you turn it on in the presence of a KRAS mutation, you can see within two weeks,
the mice get high-grade PanINs, they get invasive
carcinoma, and you can see CA19-9 is elevated in the ductal
epithelium, which is what you would expect.
This translates to a substantial decrease in survival in these
mice. And so these mice, relative to CA19-9
negative controls, so they do not have the CA19-9 alleles at
all, or in the mice that have inducible CA19-9 but
were not treated with DOX, versus those in which we added DOX to their
drinking water. You can see that when we turn on CA19-9, we have
survival, which is about as powerful as mutating
p53. And so we weren't entirely surprised because
pancreatitis does accelerate tumor genesis.
But when I started my lab, I really wanted to understand, are these direct impacts
to cell signaling and paracrine interactions?
Or is there something that we're perhaps overestimating
here? And so what we found is that when you're trying to learn how to bake a
cake, if you just study the finished product, it's very difficult to understand how
that cake came to be. So we need to watch somebody actually on a cooking show,
right? And so we only turned on CA19-9 for a few days so we could
take a step back and see what are the ingredients, what order
do they get recruited to the pancreatic tumor microenvironment?
And what we found is that three days of CA19-9 is sufficient to
dramatically expand the fibroblast population and ramp up
proliferation in that compartment.
But at the same time, we're not just turning on CA19-9.
We are remodeling the glycome. We are driving the production of different precursor
molecules. We're decreasing the levels of available substrates for other types of
glycosylation. So this is really dependent on
CA19-9.And so I turned to a tool that is clinically
relevant. This is an antibody clone called 5B1 that is highly specific
and has high affinity for CA19-9. This was originally developed by a company
called Madvax, but then was acquired by BioNTech.
And so they have tested this in clinical trials and shown that the CA19-9 blocking
antibody as a monotherapy led to a 20% stable disease
response rate in the advanced line metastatic setting, and when you combine it with
chemo, had a 27% partial response.
This study was discontinued due to sponsor decision, but we
also learned something really important from this clinical trial, in that
patients that had the highest levels of CA19-9 actually had increased clearance
of the antibody in circulation, preventing it from actually reaching the tumors.
And so this is a major challenge when you're targeting a glycan.
It's not a single protein or a single epitope.
Again, it's present multiple times on one protein on hundreds of different
proteins. And so the levels in which CA19-9 accumulates in your circulation is
extremely high. And so not only am I interested in the CA19-9
pericentrin cascade due to cool biology, but also as
alternative therapeutic interception points.
And so what we found is that you block CA19-9 with this antibody, and you normalize
the histologic architecture of the pancreas.
You have a slight decrease in collagen deposition, but you see this profound
reduction in both proliferation and fibroblast infiltration.
So how? Well,
we did the really expensive experiment in my lab, which was perhaps a mistake
now in hindsight. We did the single-cell RNAseq experiment at the three-day
time point, and using these advanced algorithms like Cell Chat
and NicheNet, what we could see is that there was this
interaction network that was strengthened when we turned on CA19-9, where you
have ductal cells interacting more with these type of CAFs called
antigen-presenting CAFs that then induced CD4 T cell
differentiation to Tregs. And this is work that was done originally, this
axis was originally discovered by Ella Iliada in Dave Tuveson's lab,
as well as in Rolf Brekken's lab.
And so we took a look and we saw indeed, there's a dramatic
expansion of these antigen-presenting CAFs, as well as an increase in
Treg differentiation, both by single-cell flow cytometry and
immunohistochemistry. And so we wanted to take a closer look about how all
this is happening, and so Rolf Brekken kindly provided these pancreatic
mesothelial cells, which are the primary source of antigen-presenting
fibroblasts in the pancreas. And we either treated them CA19-9 positive or
CA19-9 negative condition media from these pancreatic organoids, or
we did an antibody blocking experiment and measured the apCAF
differentiation. And so what we can see is that CA19-9
positive condition media can induce antigen-presenting CAF differentiation to
a greater extent than its CA19-9 negative counterpart.
And if we block CA19-9, we actually dramatically change the secreted
cytokines and secreted factors, and this leads to a
dramatic impairment in antigen-presenting
CAF differentiation. And if we take a look at our
antibody blockade experiment in vivo, you can
then again see that the antigen presenting into your differentiation decreases,
showing that this is a specific impact of CA19-9.
And so what we wanted to understand next is
basically what is driving these signals.
And CA19-9 elevation, as I mentioned, it's going to modify many
different things. A lot of those things are going to be quite subtle.
And so is there one possible mechanism that we could use to get a paper
accepted?
And so what we built on is that Rolf Brekken
in a very elegant fashion showed that ILIN alpha and TGF beta, their
combined concerted effort are what derived antigen
presenting CAF differentiation.
And so we looked at these secreted factors in our organoids, and we found
that when you induce CA19-9, you get increased expression at the gene
and protein level of ILIN alpha and TGF beta.
And if we look at the tumors in the mice after we turn on CA19-9, you can also see
the accumulation of both of these factors.
In addition, if we block ILIN alpha and TGF beta in the condition
media from these organoids, you can see an impairment in apCAF
differentiation from these pancreatic mesothelial cells.
And so we do think that this is not a novel axis, just one
that is substantially provoked by CA19-9 elevation.
So then we did the in vivo antibody blockade experiment, and then you can again
see that the combined effect of blocking both ILIN alpha and TGF
beta normalize the tissue architecture, decrease collagen
deposition. You get an overall decrease in cancer-associated
fibroblasts, and these are primarily in the antigen-presenting
compartment, as well as a decrease in Tregs.
Now, you'll notice that with ILIN alpha blocking antibody by itself, you also
impair Treg differentiation. This is a little bit difficult to dissect because
these are important for both apCAF differentiation as well as Treg
proliferation and expansion. And so when we
ported this in vitro as well, we found that apCAFs are indeed necessary
for this cascade, but I'm not going to show you that data today.
And so this is a cascade that's initiated by
CA19-9, but really hyped up
ILIN alpha and TGF beta expression. But what's the intermediary, right?
What's the CA19-9 modified protein that's doing this?
And so we went back to the original work where perhaps one of the best ones
that we've characterized so far is this secreted glycoprotein called fibulin 3,
which has many different EGF-like domains.
And we showed that this is CA19-9 modified, and when it is, it can co-precipitate
with EGF receptor to a greater extent and lead to hyperactivation of EGF
receptor, both in pancreatitis and now also we've shown in pancreatic cancer
organoids, where you see that when we turn on CA19-9, we get increased
phosphorylation of EGF receptor, and if we knock down fibulin 3, that
disappears.Now, APCAFs do not express EGF
receptor. Other types of CAFs certainly do.
But what we have seen is that EGF receptor signaling in other cell
systems can drive IL-1alpha and TGF-beta production.
And so on a whim, Heman was working on fibulin 3, Jasper was working on
the TME. I was like, "Are these actually the same project?" And it turned
out that it was. And when we knocked down fibulin 3, now we had a substantial
reduction in IL-1alpha and TGF-beta in both mouse and human organoids.
And so this to us said that this is a fibulin 3 mediated EGF receptor
dependent process, which we've also now shown both in vitro and in vivo
using pan-ERBB kinase inhibitors.
What did this do to APCAF differentiation in the in vitro differentiation
model? The fibulin 3 knocked down organoids, even in the CA19-9 positive
setting, lose their ability to induce antigen-presenting CAF
differentiation. But when I was trying to sell the in vivo
investigation of this final piece of the puzzle to my
students,
I'm an organoid person, but transplanting these organoids, it takes about 6 to
12 months for them to form tumors. And so they would like to graduate this year.
So I told them that they could use 2D cells, which if Dave is in here in the
audience, I'm sorry. It's quite blasphemous. But we used 2D cells.
We set up the same system. We knocked down fibulin 3 in the CA19-9 positive
setting. This has no impact on their in vitro
proliferation, but you can again see that it leads to a reduction in
IL-1alpha and TGF-beta production.
And so what we wanted to do is look at in vivo tumor formation.
You can see in two different independent cell lines that you have a
remarkable decrease in tumor growth in both the
volume over time as well as the endpoint.
And when we port the system over to NSG mice, we completely lose any
tumor size differences, suggesting to us that this is really immune
mediated.
And so what we wanted to, again, do is see, well, what
happens to the tumor microenvironment?
Do we reverse this immunosuppressive remodeling?
And what we find is that when you're looking for antigen-presenting CAFs, you have
to find the CAFs that are CD45 negative, but MHC positive.
And we see a dramatic reduction in those fibroblasts.
But importantly to the CAF field, I think it's important to note that we still see
plenty of myCAFs and we still see some iCAFs.
When we look at Tregs, Treg infiltration is usually an early event
in pancreas tumor genesis. But
what they essentially do is suppress the immune system.
And so we look at our CD8 T cells instead.
At endpoint, we can see a dramatic expansion in CD8 T cells.
And so I think that what we've done is kind of uncovered this really
interesting TME remodeling axis where CA19-9 kind of triggers
multiple different cascades. So certainly activating EGF receptor
in the ductal cell compartment is going to be pro-survival,
pro-growth. But at the same time, this is going to lead to remodeling
of the different immunomodulatory factors that these cancer cells can
secrete. And so I'm not saying that in the absence of CA19-9, this axis
isn't active, just that in a CA19-9 high tumor, which is about
90% of pancreas cancers, you're going to have much more
immunosuppressive TME remodeling than we are ever going to have
happen in our mice. And this increased production of IL-1alpha
and TGF-beta is going to induce APCAF differentiation, CD4 T
cell differentiation to Tregs, and inhibition of our CD8 T cells.
And so I think that this is something where
sometimes the mouse models can overestimate response.
Well, maybe that's because they lack some of these human glycan derived
axes.
And so I think this is really early days in terms of fully understanding everything
that CA19-9 does. And I'll be the first one to admit that
glycosylation is complex and difficult to study.
I'm lucky in that CA19-9 is really driven by the action of a single
enzyme, whereas in many of these other cases, you're talking about a network that
is dozens of enzymes. But I think this is a really good example where
taking a step back and understanding the biomarkers that we've used for
cancers for almost five decades now
might actually be functional. And in this case, I've shown that CA19-9
elevation triggers this immunosuppressive TME remodeling.
But there are hundreds of other CA19-9 modified proteins,
and they all change their function in slightly different ways.
And so for fibulin 3, how does this glycosylation actually
increase its binding to EGF receptor?
For the RAS therapeutics
interest in the field, we are seeing how this intersects with RAS
inhibitor response, as well as the obvious next step is to
combine CA19-9 blockade or blockade of this access with immune
checkpoint blockade, and then really going after the massive repertoire of
CA19-9 modified proteins and other glycan changes that occur
during pancreatic tumor genesis.
And so none of this work could be possible without a big team.
And so this is, again, this was work led by Heman and Jasper,
who are both finishing up their PhDs.
But we have a large support network of technicians as well as friends in the
lab that everybody kind of helps when you have a big in vivo study.
But also if any of you run an organoid program, it does require a lot of
infrastructure. I also had a ton of help with a lot of the bioinformatic
analysis from Tag Yu as well as Jonathan.
And then my immunology partners in crime, because I didn't start off as a
glycobiologist, let alone an immunologist, are Ye Zheng and Sue
Kag. And then, of course, my most
fun scientific experiment is my son, Oliver, who is now
three years old. So he has been my fearless cheerleader through all of this
work.
Thank you so much. I'd be happy to take questions.
Thank you. I know the deans of the pancreas
tumor microenvironment are sitting in the audience, so we'll defer questions to the
end. I promise to be quick. I'm wearing my pin and
tie for those of you who haven't seen it in honor of this session.
So this isMy talk on early detection.
If it'll start, start. Okay, here we go.
Okay. Early detection and interception of pancreas cancer.
So we are all excited about the improvements in survival of this disease.
When I started my lab, the five-year survival was 4%.
It's now 12%. Oh, sorry. My disclosure slide.
I'm a pathologist, so really not much to disclose here.
But anyway,
it is important to emphasize, and this is a very sobering
review that was done by Lola Rahib and Barbara Kenners and others, showing
that much of that improvement has actually come from localized
disease. Improvements are almost entirely because of the improvements we've
made in that percentage of patients with surgically resectable tumors.
And this is further emphasized here, where the chemotherapy
backbones that we have that Shubham talked about, the one-year
survival has improved because they do work well in that initial one-year
period. But then when you look at the five-year survival, this upward trajectory is
really for localized disease. The advanced disease is still mostly a flat
line. Again, this is all pre-RAS inhibitors.
It'll be very interesting to revisit this analysis in about a decade
when these inhibitors are widely available outside of the context of clinical
trials, but this is the reality today.
When we look at the trajectory of CA19-9, now I am talking about
old-fashioned biomarker CA19-9, not all the lovely data that Danny
presented.
You can see that almost a year before the clinical diagnosis, this was
done using
samples obtained from the PLCO repository, which has pre-diagnostic
samples of individuals being followed over time, so there are individuals who gave
blood samples and then at variable time points developed pancreas cancer.
So you can see that about a year before the clinical diagnosis, the
CA19-9 trajectory keeps going up,
suggesting that there is the possibility of diagnosing this disease even at
an occult stage. So the question that you can
ask, obviously is why not screen everyone above 50?
We do mammograms, colonoscopies. Why don't we do a CA19-9?
Well, the US Preventive Services Task Force, which is a
body tasked with
developing evidence-based screening guidelines, basically gives screening for
pancreas cancer in the general population a grade of D, which is a
failing grade, because not only is it not going to be helpful, it might actually do
harm. And this is a little piece of data that I got from Brian Volkman, who,
when he's not giving plenary talks on phase three trials, actually
thinks deeply about early detection.
And as you can see here,
the most important thing about a biomarker test
is not just the sensitivity and the specificity, which are the performance
criteria we are always thinking about, but the positive predictive value or
PPV. And the PPV is entirely defined by the
population in which that test is done.
So the less the prevalence of a particular entity
in that population where you're testing, the lower will be the PPV, which
means the lower is the chance that the entity
is actually present when the test is positive.
So in the general population, you could have a fantastic test, 90%
sensitive, 99% specific, but the PPV
of that will be very low in single digits.
Now you apply it to a little bit more enriched population, the PPV goes up,
and you apply to even more of an enriched population, the PPV goes up much,
much higher, to the point where you feel confident that a test is truly
positive when it's positive. And this is the reason why, and this is a whole
separate story altogether, it's a one-hour lecture by itself, why I have deep
concerns about just going out and doing ctDNA assays for pancreas cancer
in the general population because the PPV is going to be really low.
So then what do we have to do? We have to enrich these populations,
and that enrichment will come from defining who are high-risk cohorts
for pancreas cancer. Who are they?
So the first most common one that we know that is well defined is
mucinous pancreatic cysts, patients who have these
fluid-filled sacs in the pancreas called
most commonly intraductal papillary mucinous neoplasms or IPMNs.
And there are millions of us walking around with these silent IPMNs.
Approximately 15% of cancers annually arise in the
backdrop of these IPMNs. This is an example of a high-grade
IPMN that just had incipient invasion.
This is exactly what you want to catch.
Catch this pre-cancer before it becomes cancer.
And then you have individuals who have germline mutations that puts them at
variable lifetime risk for pancreatic cancer, including
mutations like BRCA1, BRCA2, and ATM, et cetera.
And again, the risk varies depending on the specific alteration, but
approximately 10% of pancreatic cancers arise in the backdrop
of these germline mutations. So that's 10 plus 15, 25%.
What about the other 75%? The so-called sporadic pancreas cancer, the
patient who just walks in and
gets diagnosed with pancreas cancer.
So there we do have some indicators of potential
high-risk factors that we could take into account, and one of which is new
onset hyperglycemia and diabetes, which can be a harbinger
of an underlying pancreas cancer or an incipient pancreas cancer.
So it turns out that about a quarter of patients have full on
new onset diabetes months to a couple of years before the diagnosis
of pancreas cancer, but a much larger number have some or
other dysglycemia, whether it's impaired glucose tolerance
or pre-diabetes or something going on with their glycemic control
that happens months to years before the diagnosis of pancreatic cancer.
And really, a tribute to Suresh Chari, who was at Mayo
Clinic for almost three decades, who really has
identified this relationship between hyperglycemia and diabetes
preceding cancer diagnosis. You can see right here, patients with pancreas cancer,
this is when the cancer is diagnosed, and you can start seeing the
loss of glycemic control that happens months to at least a couple of years before
the diagnosis. All the major papers are listed
here.And this has been validated by many groups
in retrospective data.
You can see some of the papers here.
And even when there have been AI-based algorithms that have been
developed, this one is
from Dana-Farber,
that was published in "Nature Medicine" a few years back.
But there have been other algorithms as well, including one that was just presented
from NYU by one of our medical students at this ACR.
Diabetes is always one of the features that rises to the top.
So this is something that is clearly present in the
context of a risk factor or a harbinger
of pancreas cancer. And in fact, even
patients who have precancerous lesions like these IPMNs, when their
IPMN progresses to an invasive cancer, this is work from
one of my NYU colleagues, you can then develop new onset diabetes in
that setting.
So I just wanted to spend one slide on this.
This is a wonderful resource that I was part of
building. This was an NCI-funded study to build a
prospective cohort on new onset diabetes and
hyperglycemia, under the auspices of the Early Detection
Research Network, or EDRN of the NCI.
And we have more than 2,200 confirmed, and
this was
EMR-confirmed, very well-annotated new onset
diabetes participants that completed the three-year study follow-up period.
We have over 6,800 blood samples. So if there is
anyone here interested in biomarkers or working on biomarkers in the
context of this particular cohort, you can apply to
get access to these samples from the EDRN.
We have access to the whole cohort. Again, this is the kind of studies you can do.
This is just CA19-9. We have a lot of assays
obviously going on in this very precious sample set.
There are companies like Clearnote Health that are also doing studies in this
sample set. So they are available.
You need to apply to get them from the EDRN.
But here we can see, for example, in patients, the CA19-9 crosses the
threshold again 12 months or earlier before the
diagnosis. So again, this is a good foundation now on
which you can build better biomarkers for earlier diagnosis of this disease.
So this is a roadmap that we wrote with the EDRN a few years ago, which
is to really define who
are these subsets of individuals in whom we can enable
biomarker studies to
facilitate early detection. So this is the who, the clinical risk groups,
those with family history, new onset diabetes, mucinous cystic lesions.
I didn't talk about chronic pancreatitis. That's again an area that Danny studies.
And then the how is the biomarkers.
CA19-9 is obviously the old guard, but now a lot of new
work is going on in this area. And where is it?
Where is the lesion? And this is where obviously a lot of work is
ongoing in terms of radiomics and AI to better find those
tiny lesions that would be missed by the radiologist's eye.
And so just to give a plug for the role of AI in this entire
journey, Eric Topol and I wrote this little one-pager a couple of years
back. There's a lot of AI at this meeting, but I really think this is
an area where AI, beginning with identification of who is
at risk, starting with mining electronic health records,
to using it to identify patterns in liquid biopsies such as
fragmentomic patterns for tiny lesions, to
AI-enabled imaging and improving the resolution of a
human eye would be very, very important. So lots of work ongoing here.
Just wanted to give a landscape view before I pivot to the
second half of my talk, which is on interception.
So early detection of pancreatic cancer in high-risk cohorts.
So many, many academic centers
in the country run these surveillance studies where
individuals who have germline mutations or who have cystic
lesions, they come in, they get an imaging study done, maybe
get a CA19-9 drawn, and then they're told to come back in six months or a
year. But it's really very passive follow-up.
We don't really do anything for these individuals.
Yet it's a very motivated group, amazing performance status in
most individuals. These are not patients with cancer, and so they
really want something done. And so is there an opportunity to do something actively
for these individuals? And this is where the concept of interception comes in,
which is a way of basically stopping cancer in its tracks.
The foundational commentary
was written by Elizabeth Blackburn, the Nobel laureate for telomerase,
and she came up with this term cancer interception,
literally based on interception in football, in American
football. And if you look at the commentary, there is a figure of
the quarterback being intercepted.
So it literally is based on that particular analogy.
So the question is: Can we intercept pancreas cancer?
And so I want to talk about a couple of vignettes. One is vaccines.
So this was preclinical work that was done in the lab of
Liz Jaffee at Hopkins.
Her grad student and I spent a lot of time on the microscope
measuring the PanIN lesions in these mice that got a Listeria-based
vaccine. That's the paper that was published.
And based on that data that showed that a vaccine was able to
attenuate PanIN progression in this mouse model,
Liz and our colleagues launched this.
Initially, this was a study that was done in patients who underwent surgical
resection, so they were diagnosed with cancer, underwent resection, and then
received the vaccine in adjuvant setting just for safety and feasibility purposes.
This is very similar to the ELISIO trial that Shubham talked
about or the mRNA vaccine trial that
Vinod talked about. These are all individuals who already got diagnosed, underwent
surgery, and got the vaccine in their adjuvant setting or in the
neo-adjuvant setting.But then the question is, can you do this
in a non-cancer high-risk context?
And this is
really the girl boss team of cancer vaccines at
Hopkins, Liz, Neha, Nilo, and Amanda.
And they were funded initially through the Stand Up to Cancer Lost Garden
Foundation, ACR Interception Dream Team, which I had the privilege of leading.
And actually, Will was also a part of that team when he was in Tyler's lab.
And this began the first vaccine trial targeted against mutant
KRAS.
It was a synthetic long peptide, SLP vaccine, against the six common
mutations,
and was done in patients who were high risk because they had germline mutations.
They didn't have necessarily discernible lesions in the
pancreas,
or they may have had something suspicious, but they didn't have cancer.
And so this is just one piece of data I wanted to share.
This is courtesy of Neha Zaidi, who really is leading all of these efforts at
Hopkins. So in these patients, again, these are high-risk individuals who
don't have cancer, vaccination with a KRAS vaccine
induces
mutant KRAS-specific T-cell responses.
Remember, there are no tissues here.
The only surrogate you have of immune response here is what you
can find from PBMCs. But what you can see here
is more than 90% of patients developed at least
some mutant KRAS-specific T-cell responses.
More than 80% developed them against all six antigens, all
six KRAS antigens, all the colors you see on those bars that they were
vaccinated against. And this is the most exciting piece of the data.
Ultimately, interception depends on longevity of the response, and you heard that
from the talk that Vinod gave that was featured on NBC
News, that six years after vaccination, these patients had lasting
T-cell responses. We're not that far along, but you can see here that
one year after vaccination, again, these patients got three prime
doses and one boost, and that was it.
Still, one year later, they still have persistent
KRAS-specific T-cell responses in the blood
suggesting that there is ongoing immune activity.
Now, again, whether there'll be a clinical readout, this is obviously a lot more
challenging than a recurrence setting where the runway is
shorter, but at least we know that these T-cells are there.
Okay, KRAS inhibitors. I got to talk about that.
So can you do interception with KRAS inhibitors?
So in 2023 with Raghu Kalluri at MD Anderson, when I was there, we published this
initial study, and that was with MRTX1133, a great preclinical
drug that unfortunately did not make it to the clinic.
But you can see that this is a G12D inhibitor, and this is a
KC mouse. So those of you who study the disease, this is a G12D
model. And you can see very nice attenuation of panins when
the treatment is started early. You can see, it's complete
disappearance, to be honest, of all panins here.
He has since done this now with the RevMed-9805
drug, which is again, the G12D inhibitor.
And again, you can see very nicely, in the KC model, which is
just the KRAS disappearance of the panin lesions.
And then in the KPC model, which also has p53 and has much
faster progression, same thing. With this early treatment, you get
regression of panin lesions. Today, in just a
little bit, Minh Tan, I don't know if he's in the audience, but from
Penn with Bob Vonderheide and Ben Stanger, just published this paper
in Science on cancer interception with KRAS inhibitors in the
KPC model. And they used tool compounds that are basically
the tool compounds for deraxone, rasib, and zoldanrasib.
And he's going to talk about this this afternoon.
I encourage you to go and listen to his talk if you can.
Ben Neil and I wrote an editorial
as an accompaniment to this. And the bottom line is they really
primed this strategy for the clinic, if you so
will. And there's a couple of nuances here that they did that I think is
helpful as we consider moving this strategy to the clinic.
One is that they showed that even brief periods of dosing were
effective in reducing pre-cancer burden, which again, is something that you might
think about when we translate to humans, like, do they have to take this
lifelong or can we do short bursts and then stop?
And the second is this metronomic dosing, one week off, one week on, which is
like drug holidays we do in patients for reducing toxicity that
Shubham talked about in his talk.
My last slide.
As the chair, I think I have a little bit of prerogative to go rogue.
And I'm on the West Coast. So biohacking
KRAS. We are all here amongst biohackers.
So that lovely lady sitting in the second row, Marina,
threw a bomb in our field by showing that all of us, many of us, have
panin lesions, including in our 20s.
That's a 20-year-old with panin lesions.
And so there's a lot of panin burden out there, but obviously, and thank goodness
for that, most of us don't get pancreas cancer.
But is there an opportunity to do something in terms of preventing this
disease in terms of those who are at high risk?
And so I promised some of my friends in the audience I would use
the word cleanse in my talk, and here it is.
So we came up with this concept of KRAS cleanse.
So you have oral KRAS inhibitors, not the ones we have now.
I think they're still too toxic, but it's getting better.
Even in the cancer context, they're getting better.
So a little bit of provocative idea.
Oral KRAS inhibitors for a few weeks in these high-risk individuals above a
certain age.
You take it for a few weeks, you cleanse all the KRAS from your
body. You come back next year, you get another KRAS cleanse.
Maybe add vaccines annually as a booster to sustain the immune response.
Pipe dream, but so was drugging KRAS 10 years
ago, and look where we are. So thank you very much.
And, again, we are happy to take questions from the audience.
I'm like in an FBI interrogation. I can't see anything.
So if you're coming here, just alternate and start talking.
Introduce yourself.
Yeah. Philip Dennis from NovaBridge.
A question about the cryptic antigens and the aberrant translation.
Is the machinery normal in cells that really take
part in this? In other words, initiation factors, elongation factors, is
that normal? And then as a result of the aberrant translation,
is ER stress a common phenomenon in the cells that do that?
Yeah, it's a great question. In terms of the machinery, so we don't know in
terms of mapping out the machinery.
Others have done a little bit into this.
So Jonathan Udell, not in pancreatic cancer, has
actually done some work showing that certain
ribosomal subunits are actually just the
stoichiometry is slightly different in cancer cell context,
potentially promoting this non-canonical translation.
We don't have data for that in pancreatic cancer, and we actually
have not looked at ER stress as well.
Because it might be able to be exploited.
Yeah, 100%.
I think somebody's over there.
Hi, I'm David Barrett from Kite Pharma. I'm a T-cell guy.
I have a question about the cryptic antigens.
Really one can envision that patients will either have their own
T-cells that recognize the cryptic antigens, but they haven't been able to be
engaged in a population that doesn't have them.
Do you see a difference potentially in where you would focus your treatment
strategy? Trying to awaken an endogenous T-cell versus adding an
exogenous TCR to it?
No, it's a great question. So,
for the sake of time, did not get into this.
How do we reconcile, do these actually provoke an endogenous T-cell
response, or do we need to provoke it exogenously, either
through vaccines or obviously through cell therapy?
There is some data to suggest that these are less effectively
cross-presented by professional APCs, suggesting that the
patients may just be ignorant of this class of antigens, which may
work to our benefit, right? If we can provoke a T-cell response through either
vaccines or through cell therapy,
or just kind of bypass it altogether through cell therapy.
These may have never been subjected to immune surveillance and so
may just be sitting ducks waiting for a T-cell response.
Pratap, go ahead.
They're all great talks. Thank you.
I'm Pratap Kumar from UT San Antonio.
It's a general question for any one of you can answer.
Do you clinically either in the RAS study,
presented by Dr. Pant, do you see any specific differences in terms
of gender specificity in the treatments that you are seeing?
Or even in terms of pan-lesion sometime, do you see any...
It's for both?
Yeah. We haven't done those analysis.
As far as differences, I think the question was, do you give a RAS inhibitor
difference in gender?
We haven't looked at that, but Panin, I don't know.
I don't think so.
Not immediately, but I would say that maybe that needs to be looked at a little
bit more,
in detail. Won't be surprised. I don't know.
Marina?
Marina Pasqualemayero from the University of Michigan. Question for Dani.
What happens to the other fibroblasts when they see cancer cells that
have or do not have
CA19-9?
You get an expansion in all of them.
Yeah, so we've measured ICAFS and MYCAF, they also go up.
So when we shut down the access at any interception
point, what happens is that you
basically restore the normal MYCAF-like architecture of the
fibroblasts, and you have fewer APCAFs, as well as a little bit
less ICAFS.
And then do you think these shifts are because the fibroblasts
are
plastic and go into another fate, or are you actually
losing them because
they die?
It's a great question. We do see a decrease in
proliferation in the compartment, but we don't see cell
death, but we might also not be looking at the right time point, because that
analysis was done
at endpoint. But I think that it's a great question because I'm
not sure what happens to a differentiated APCAF when
they stop receiving IL1 alpha and TGF beta.
I don't think anybody has figured that out yet.
And everyone, I'm very much in favor of the KRAS clans.
Thank you.
I think there's a question there.
Yeah. Andy Gunnison, Ohio State University. My question's for Dani.
Related to the secreted CA19-9, does it have a paracrine effect on
non-cancer cells in the same manner as it did to the autocrine of the
IL1 alpha and TGF beta?
Yeah. So other CA19-9 modified proteins act on
different constituents of the TME.
And so we have several stories that we're working on going
after them one by one. It's quite inefficient when you have a list
that's hundreds of proteins long.
So I need to talk to somebody about how to do this more efficiently.
But,
so CA19-9, just from the glycobiology side of it, its only known
receptor is E-selectin. So we have a separate study.
I didn't talk about how that interaction between CA19-9 that remains
bound to the cancer cell surface actually mediates extravasation at distant
metastasis sites. And that's, if you go back to the original,
the OG job of CA19-9 is in leukocyte
rolling and adhesion at sites of inflammation.
And so cancer seldom reinvents something.
It usually adopts something that was originally in play during inflammation or
development. And so we're going after multiple different axes, and
they're each mediated by a different kind of glycan receptor interaction.
I can't tell, but I think there are no more questions.
So if that's the case, then thank you all for coming, and hopefully, we are
turning the tide in the fight against pancreas cancer. Thank you.
Great job.
Thank you.
Good
job.